الانتخابات التركيه كانت استثنائيه هذه
المره من حيث اعلى نسبه مشاركه اذ فقط
88% وكذلك من حيث تاجل حسم الانتخابات
الرئاسيه لجوله ثانيه وذلك لاول مره في
تاريخ تركيا لماذا جوله ثانيه لان المرشح
لمنصب الرئاسه يحتاج الى اكثر من 50% من
الاصوات للفوز بهذا المنصب وهو ما لم يحصل
عليه اي من المرشحين الاربعه وفق النتائج
التي اعلن عنها المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات
وفي الجوله الجديده سيتنافس اعلى مرشحين
من حيث عدد الاصوات وبطبيعه الحال هما
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الذي حصد
49.5 في المئه ومنافسه كلجدار اوغلو الذي
حصل على
44.8% من الاصوات بينما توزعت بقيه النسب
على المرشحين الاخرين
هنا يبرز سؤال مهم جدا ساساله لمدير مكتب
الجزيره في تركيا استاذ عبد العظيم هل
يمكن التنبؤ بنتائج الجوله الثانيه طبعا
من الصعب ان نتحدث عن نتائج مؤكده لكن
نستطيع ان نعطي مؤشرات المؤشرات
ناخذها من الحزبين المتنافسين او من فريقي
الشخصيين المتنافسين فريق الرئيس رجب
الطيب اردوغان اعطى انطباع انهم مرتاحون
للذهاب الى جوله ثانيه في الانتخابات هناك
مصادر داخل الحزب العداله والتنميه قالت
انهم يفضلون الذهاب الى جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات باعتبار ان هذا في هذه الجوله
حتى لو استطاع الرئيس الوصول الى 50 ما لم
يستطع فانه سيصل الى رقم وفارق ضئيل جدا
لا يعطيه قوه في انتاج هذه الانتخابات
وسيعطي فرصه للتشكيل اما فريق
فهم من الواضح كان هناك حده في التشكيك في
الانتخابات اولا من قبل اكرم الامام اوغلو
ومن سوريا واش لكن خطاب في جدار اوغلو كان
خطابا هادئا نوعا ما اكثر من السابق
والملاحظ انه لم يقل انهم سيفوزون كما كان
يتحدث في دعايته الانتخابيه قال سنبقى
نكافح الى النهايه يعني اعطى شعور انهم
يشعرون او انهم يحسون بانهم
فرصه فوزهم في الجوله الثانيه باتت اصعب
وبالتالي الانطباع الذي اعطاه
الفريقين ان فرص اردوغان ربما تكون افضل
في الجوله الثانيه منها من فرص منافسه
كمال ستذهب اصوات المرشحين الذين خرجا من
السباق
طبعا بالتحديد نحن نتحدث عن سنان اوغان
الذي حصل على
خمسه فاصل ثلاثه او اربعه وحصل على
مليونين و800 الف صوت في هذه الانتخابات
وكان مفاجاه في هذه الانتخابات عند قراءه
اصوات هؤلاء الناخبين نعرف ان هؤلاء
ينتمون الى التيار القومي المتشدد وهو
اقصى اليمين في في التيار القومي هؤلاء
لمن سيعطون هذا سؤال صعب جدا لانهم لديهم
تحفظات على كلا المرشحين هؤلاء اذا لم
يعطون اصواتهم فستكون النسبه باريحيه
بفارق خمس نقاط لصالح اردوغان اذا احجموا
عن الانتخابات اذا اعطوا لمن سيعطون
بالتاكيد من الصعب ان نقول انهم يمكن ان
يذهبون الى تحالفك الجدار او يعطون
اصواتهم لك باعتبار ان تحفظهم الاساسي على
مشاركه حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي وممث حزب
اليسار وحزب العمال حزب اليسار الاخضر
وحزب العمال الداعمين لكل جدار اوغلو لا
يمكن لسنان اوغان او من ينتمي للحركه
القوميه ان يبرر هذا التحالف باي صيغه من
الصيغ وبالتالي اردوغان ماذا يحتاج من
هؤلاء المليونين وثمانمائه اذا ما قلنا ان
هذه الكتله التصويتيه ستصوت اذا اردوغان
حصل على 800 الف من هذه المليون 800 سيفوز
بشكل مرتاح في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات شكرا لك استاذ عبد العظيم
يتعل
ق بالسباق الرئاسي في تركيا
[موسيقى]